[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hey Damon
welcome to the show Hi how are you guys
doing we are doing great how can we
help so I've made
a division about two years ago that
haunts me up until today okay where me
and my family we were renting and um we
decided that we were going to purchase a
house together and we all put like maybe
like 10,000 each to get like 50,000 to
put get the
house and the house was
420 and at a
2.8% so ever since we moved to the house
I haven't lived there because I was
still going to school and I was still
commuting spending maybe up to 500 per
month in
gas and um
we decided that we were going to we made
a verbal agreement that we were going to
continue to pay even though we don't
live there anymore and I realize how bad
of a division that was and I want to
tell him that um I can't continue to pay
this anymore but knowing how my family
is I know Thanksgiving is not going to
look the same for me if I tell them this
and I don't know where to go and I
haven't been able to sleep I just St in
space all day like I don't know what to
do oh my gosh okay so who all when you
say your family is this like your
parents and siblings or who does this
what who do what makes up this parent
parents and siblings parents and
siblings and is someone renting this
house right now since you all aren't
living in
it we we all are living in it but we all
put together to contribute to the mort
grid and the
do but in the past year I haven't lived
there and I've been paying religiously
non-stop every month towards the bills
600 and another 100 towards like
utilities but 600 towards mortgage and
so you're renting somewhere
else I'm living with a friend because
it's closer to my job okay but I'm not
able to save and my student loans are
about to kick in and I have credit cards
and
I just don't know what to do well sure
you do you know exactly what to do th
this is you said you're in a fog I'm
using my words you said you just stare
into nothingness all day long I mean
this is absolutely shutting you down
you're not going to be able to live
forever with your with your friend
you're going to get kicked out of that
eventually this is slowly breaking you
down you know exactly what to do you
have to sit down with your parents and
your siblings and say I know I gave you
a verbal agreement but here's where my
life is and here's how I got there
student loans you you show them
everything I can't afford to pay you
$700 a month and they're going to say
Well then why don't you live here and
you go I don't want to live here and
you're going to tell them all the
reasons why you don't live there and
it's going to suck but you're going to
have to choose your own livelihood and I
mean like as in living well-being you're
going to have to choose you and you're
going to have to have a big boy
conversation and own it if they get mad
at you for a while and Thanksgiving
sucks I would rather have a sucky
Thanksgiving or two or three than a
sucky
life yes yeah and I think and I also
think it's fair because on their end
they're thinking yeah well we've agreed
to this and you're and you're and you're
breaking that but Damon but to Ken's
point it has to like this doesn't
sustain this you can't you can't live
like this so I think that even saying I
understand I'm backing out of what I
said but I I don't even have the I don't
have the ability I don't have the
ability anymore to do this and so if
there's something else I can do to maybe
help but I I think to Damon like I think
owning it is is um a very humble thing
to do and I would do that but also for
your sake and I would hope your I would
pray your parents which I always think
the best about relationship I'm always
like you're I'm sure your parents are
wonderful oh they so you would pray
Thanksgiving is going to be wonderful
you would pray that your parents would
say yeah we see this in our son we see
the numbers and the
situation and we don't want to put that
on our son how old are you
you I'm 30 how old were you when you did
this
deal I'm 28 okay so was just two years
ago do they find it like was the was
there going to be a point that you guys
would have this like paid off and you
would split the equity like what was the
plan the plan was because we moved to
America So the plan was just to have
somewhere to live and okay have a family
home yeah and everyone contribute will
this put them with your parents do you
know the math of
when you do choose to stop
paying will they still be able to cover
the
payment there there are enough adults in
the house
where they will be able to cover the
payment if I stop paying they will be
able to pay like maybe 200 extra and you
know they just have to adjust their
spending habit yeah but one of my
siblings already cut Communications with
me attempting to have a conversation
about this and that's the kind of person
they are yeah I'm sorry about that I I
don't make light of that but it it I
mean you have no choice you either
choose to not have an awkward situation
with them or you choose to have an awful
life and d and that's and can I say if
they choose to cut off communication
with you because of this that's that's
their choice yeah you can't you can't
control that and it's would be one of
the most
painful terrible scenarios when there's
fractured relationships in life I think
it's just I mean there's there's grief
in that I mean it's it's
terrible um but but you didn't choose
that you still want relationship with
them you just can't make a $700 payment
to a house that you don't live in
anymore and that's what you're asking to
be out of not out of the family um and
so if they choose to take a different
route sadly that that is on
them yeah where did you where did you
guys where did you guys moved from where
you guys from
originally we moved from um New Jersey
to New
York but before you said we came to
America oh we moved from uh the
Caribbean okay because I do know too you
know that certain level of loyalty in
your word and certain cultures right
holds way more weight than others right
so I I know that that sometimes is at
play as well um but I do I I would own
what I what I signed up for and that I
can't fulfill
it but them choosing to not communicate
with you anymore that's that's their
stuff right and if it's not this and if
those are the kind of people they are I
hate to say it there's going to be
something else in life you marry someone
they don't agree with you raise your
kids a certain you know what I mean like
yeah eventually that that happens but
I'm so I'm so sorry D you aren a bad
person I I think you were calling for
permission we don't have the power to
give it to you but I I will tell you
that we're in agreement on what you
should do and so are you and you need to
do this you're not a bad person for
doing this and I think you need to give
yourself some forgiveness for not living
up to what you agreed to and knowing
that you got to make a different
decision which is the right decision so
do it and move forward